hello and welcome to a special edition
of spectator TV I'm Katie Balsam joined
by Fraser Nelson and James Forsyth now
we've just heard what neither the prime
minister or Chancellor would call a
budget but a series of announcements
that are having repercussions as the day
has gone on James can you just fill us
in on what causes announced in the
Commons chamber today and what the
initial reaction from the markets is of
course it causing stood up at 9 30 this
morning and you know we've been told
that there'll be more rabbits than we'll
ship down and it didn't disappoint he
has abolished v45p rate of income tax he
has brought forward a 1p cut in the
basic rates of income tax he has
canceled the corporation tax rise he has
reversed the National Insurance rise and
abolished the Health and Social care
Levy going forward he has as you
predicted he would on coffee house
yesterday
um uh introduced v80 free shopping for
foreign tourists coming to the UK uh he
has done a he has changed the starting
rate for stamp Duty like raising it
quite considerably for first-time buyers
there are a whole series of measures the
upshot of which the UK government will
be borrowing 70 billion more than 70
billion pounds more than it said it
expected to in April now I think it is
first day that the markets have not uh
reacted entirely uh in the way the
government would have hoped to this the
pound is at the time we are recording
this down at below 110.
um and the cost of government borrowing
uh is is rising and has risen at a
relatively uh rapid rate today
and so I think this is the essential
gamble that Liz trust and what's your
question are taking is twofold
it is that they can boost the rate of
growth of the economy to this two and a
half percent that they they talk about
which means that the kind of public
finances all begin to add up and they
can then win a political argument about
the fact that you know in the first uh
fiscal event of this government they
have decided to abolish the top rate uh
the 45b rate of income tax uncapped
Bankers bonuses you know do lots of
things that you know politically
cautious conservative leaders have
thought would have been would have
thought was too risky and so I think
everything now depends on whether this
project well sorry is this not
let's call it what it is yeah this
budget whether this budget delivers
growth or not I think the one thing
I think we can all agree on whatever you
think of the the overall packages that
when the exit poll drops in 2024 we will
look back on this budget as being the
reason for whatever result we end up
seeing no Fraser James mentioned some of
the market reaction I think what's
interesting here is you could have
Minister say oh it doesn't matter we
don't be judged by this today but yet
there was a tweet uh from Christopher
who's the chief Secretary of the
Treasury quite early on
um and it was a quote tweet of a
journalist who had pointed out that
actually straight after quasiquatang's
plan for growth
um actually the pan was doing fairly
well and he suggested this show that
there was faith in the government's plan
but then something happened after yes
the pound then tanked and it wasn't it
wasn't the only thing that started a
tank the the ftse 100 tanked as well you
think that's strange in a pro-enterprise
budget why why would the share us taking
so much and that's because they now
think that interest rates are going to
have to go that much higher now perhaps
up to five percent sense and and people
previously they thought about 4.2 4.5
percent and so we're seeing all these
ramifications now I think what the
government did wrong was because it's
suspended the office for Budget
responsibility there wasn't really any
planners to have this money really is
going to be paid for you can borrow shed
loads of money if you come up with a
slightly more coherent plan as to how
you're going to pay it back in the end
but you decided to dispense with all of
that
um and I think that that discombobulated
the markets a bit so not only have we
had the pound taking but we've had the
guilt yields how much the government's
going to have to spend on its borrowing
heading up to about four percent now
just a couple of years ago the markets
were thinking they would never get above
0.5 let alone afford now that's going to
cost serious it's going to cost billions
of pounds more of the government so the
market reaction is not at all what they
would have wanted now it's quite
possible that the markets have got it
wrong they get quite a lot wrong it's
quite possible the economists discount
the pro-growth effects of all the
reforms now today the economists after
all completely underestimated David
Cameron when he wanted to cut employers
tax and as a result you had employment
growing all the way through the Cameron
years every single year astonished the
markets so that's not to say that this
budget is a failure it's just to say
that right now you'd be hard pushed to
find that many people who are confident
about its success now this is a gamble
well I must admit I I started today
thinking but they probably were going to
deliver on the on the sheer variable
promises they made here we promised a
game-changing budget now I thought
you're going to need a lot of tax cuts
to make that but right enough we have
had the biggest tax cutting budget in 50
years that's if you include the tax
Rises that have been abolished as well
as attackers that are actually being cut
and to actually cut taxes for the
highest earners is politically
incredibly audacious so the biggest
winner is right now of course of the
highest paid so you've got people who
were paying I think with Cooperative tax
effectively he was just about 48 now
it's going to go down to 42 percent
that's a pretty big tax cut but then
again if you're average person you're
not just getting one percent off income
tax basic rate you're getting
um two and a half percent of National
Insurance that was split between
employer and employee so that's a pretty
sizable tax cut as well so this is
certainly a government serious about
cutting taxes whatever else you say
about quasi court and English trust you
can't say they were not serious about
delivering the tax cuts and there's
other areas as well that we haven't even
spoken of which in the north themselves
would be a very big deal the ir35 for
example is an accounting procedure for
how Freelancers are taxed that should
really help get people back into
self-employment and there is talk um of
getting I think it's 120 000 more people
back into work by tightening the welfare
conditions now given that with something
like 5.3 million people on out of work
benefits getting another 0.1 back is not
that big a deal but all of this is in in
the right direction if you're a supply
side reformer what makes people like me
slightly nervous is that we wonder how
well it's been thought through we're um
I've spoken to yeah it's funny that I I
am a classic liberal I always have been
I've always thought that countries are a
fairer and um
stronger and more cohesive when the
government gives more power back to
people lets them keep more of their
money so people like me should be
delighted today but instead I'm feeling
a little bit nervous because I'm not
quite sure if enough has been done to
prepare the ground for it to explain to
the markets what's happening because
ultimately the markets will decide are
they going to lend all of this money to
the British government there's a massive
amount James was saying 70 billion
pounds more they want to borrow now are
the markets going to do that and on what
terms I spoke to somebody earlier on
today who's feeling very pessimistic
about it he was saying that he isn't
going to really believe if he gets his
tax cut in April because it might not
this government might not even last
until then the markets might just decide
no we've had enough of this there might
be a spiral and it all might go downhill
so this is a gamble I think and one that
will take quite a few days to settle and
perhaps the biggest test will be to see
if anybody is seriously upgrading their
growth forecasts as a result
James clearly I think as Fraser points
out the markets are still trying to work
out what exactly has gone on and there
is a serious questions to it has enough
been done to prepare
um but Liz trust is in a Race Against
Time so both you and I have written
about and the sense I've gotten those
around her was that ultimately they
thought we have to do everything in this
event because
a you need all the time you can for the
next election to try and boost growth
but two her political Capital her
political stocks probably never been
higher probably higher this morning than
this afternoon and so therefore when the
longer you go on the more other problems
dominate events outside of your control
also party management gets harder and so
that might explain how he got to here
but do you think Liz trust and quasi
Quantum will still be feeling as
confident at the time we're recording
around 4pm as they were this morning at
9 00 a.m not to put too much weight on
the Chris philp tweet but I think it is
interesting because it does suggest that
they didn't expect the kind of reaction
you're seeing today because otherwise
you would think cautiously well I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
highlight that as the metric on which we
want to be judged by in case it goes the
wrong way I think the question for them
as you say they are a prime minister and
a Chancellor in a hurry they know that
they've got 18 months to get growth
going so they parl all these measures in
I think one thing that I think with the
benefit of hindsight would have actually
benefited them would have actually been
to have an obr forecast today because I
think the lack of the forecast it almost
made it a little bit look like they were
piling all the stuff in here because
they didn't want the you know the
external examiner to report on what it
would mean and so you therefore as aware
of these things the most negative
predictions about what it's going to
mean often in the vacuum although it's
worth noting that that more than 70
million figure is from the treasury Zone
numbers
I think the real I think I think I think
the biggest problem they have with the
markets is the UK economy has grown very
slowly since the 2008 financial crash
and you know so although two and a half
percent Trend growth does not sound that
ambitious it is essentially doubling
what has been the trend growth rate of
the economy since then and I think
people are like well how are you going
to do that how and how politically
sustainable are the measures that you're
going to take to do that and I mean they
are trying some things you know for
example it's quite clear what they're
trying to do with these investment zones
kind of you know planning reform kind of
yeah place by place the problem is it
doesn't quite have the same Big Bang
effect it does if you manage to
liberalize the system Nationwide or
england-wide because it's devolved and
so I mean I think those are the
challenges I mean the other big
uh political challenge for them is they
are betting that the the the the the the
growth can smash through these arguments
about distribution
but I think I think one of the
challenges is that the headline measure
today is this abolition of the 45p rate
and that is what they're gonna have to
have a big argument about now the reason
that you know George Osborne didn't
abolish it just took it down to 45p the
reason it hasn't ever gone
has been that you know no one was quite
prepared to expend the political capital
of having this fight and I think that
you know that is now going to dominate
politics and I mean you've got labor
Conference next week they will go for it
I mean there's an interesting question
about how labor attack it do they just
attack it as you know a tax cut for the
rich or do they say it's wrong that
someone on 51 000 pounds a year is
paying the same amount of tax as someone
on 100 same marginal tax rate as someone
150 000 pounds so I mean there are some
dilemmas for labor here but I own the
Jews but also do they not just say that
the Tories are failing by their own
standards because cozy quartet has given
them a big stick to beat him with he
says he said that he wants to get growth
of two and a half percent so sure you
can attack Tories for cutting taxes you
can attack if you're a labor but
fundamentally surely what you want to
say to the swing virtues is that even by
their own standard the Tories are
failing they promised you two and a half
percent growth and they haven't
delivered this I mean the other states
that label will use which they've been
handed by this is when a conservative
transfer about a cycle of stagnation
when the Tories have been in power for
12 years you do have an argument going
that you know look come on what what why
should you carry on voting for these
people when they themselves are saying
that the economic results of the last 12
years have been disappointing
now when it comes to the MP reaction
you've had former cabinet minister
Julian Smith coming out and actually
saying that the 45p cut is wrong at a
time of cost of living and it's the
wrong decision Fraser do you think there
can be nerves among Tory MPS perhaps
even some ministers as they look at
where the pound is going and perhaps
also worry about the political
ramifications well not so much for the
pound because of course if you're an
exporter this is good for you I mean
foreign currency is a double-edged sword
as is a rising currency so that is less
politically tricky than trying to sell
tax cuts for the rich that's one of the
hardest things to sell if you're a Tory
MP if you're up there doing canvassing
you'll be facing somebody who's really
traveling difficulty even with the fuel
price cap to balance the budget and they
will know but the people have been given
the biggest break in this country are
those over 150 Grand it opens them up to
the acquisition of the party of the Rich
and this is what stopped them abolishing
the upper race I mean David Cameron
wanted us to do a George Osborne did
Rishi sunak did but none of them dared
to do it because they thought that
politically it would be so damaging but
it would take away whatever gain they
may get by bringing the rate of tax down
to the standard 40p oh by the way should
I say in Scotland if Nicholas sturgeon
doesn't do this which you might not then
you'd end up with a very big difference
in the top rate of text to Scotland and
in England so that would be another side
effect of this that politically
um a lot now depends on these these
seeds that they find in actually bearing
fruit there isn't much time there is I I
reckon about 18 months she's got really
to to prove that she's brought more to
Britain than simply record amount of
national debt and record amount of um I
mean sure like the the stamp Duty will
help but
um it's also going to be very expensive
to get a mortgage I mean you're not
going to be getting any of these two
percent rates anytime soon I mean you
recently renewed your more education
whatever read did you get pretty good I
don't upset those
you told me not to get a fixed rate
mortgage and you told me I'd made a
mistake and you said I should go for a
variable and I'm now feasting on Humble
Pie akt because you first saw what I did
not that the markets were going to go
way higher of an expectation and what
looked to me like a topic fixed rate
that you got now looks like the sale of
a century so Euro quids in well the
variable rate it's gonna be the best way
it's going to be 4.5 perhaps five
percent shouldn't we have one of these
disclaimers this is not Financial advice
that you have yeah I'm not a c before I
would advise anybody not to follow my
own personal financial advice I think
they're two interesting questions which
follow from this the classic physical
conservative response would be well look
if you're going to do this you've got
you've got to have spending cuts you
know if you're going to cut tax by this
much the state has got to stop doing
some things and if they had done that
today they would have sent it single to
the market of course yeah I mean I think
if they'd announce some spending cuts at
the same time the markets would not be
reacting where they would but the
problem you've got now politically is
the politics pulls in the opposite way
of Economics because we're going to have
public arguments about public sector pay
in the coming months and it's going to
be quite hard to explain why nurses and
teachers should have a below inflation
um a real terms pay cut a low inflation
pay rise uh when the government has just
shown as the government has said such
confidence it can just borrow more money
to fund the things that it wants and so
that's attention there I think there is
also Australia said there's tension with
the bank right which is it's not just
for the bank I think is going to raise
interest rates it's that the bank is
continuing with quantitative tightening
so that means there is even more UK
government debt in the market for people
to to absorb and I think this is quite
interesting because Jerry Lyons who is
one of the Architects of trust economics
he wrote a piece earlier this week
saying urging the bank not to do QT at
the moment saying you know this is not
the right moment for quantitative timing
they voted this week unanimously to go
ahead with it and so I think that
tension between the bank and the
government is one of the other things to
watch in the coming months well one of
the things I'm fascinated by is what
happens if it all goes wrong like say
the markets do go out of control we do
do a strike and let's trust us to choose
does she then
um cut spending or does she abandon some
of her tax Rises what do you think James
I I think she is not going to increase
taxes I think this is absolutely kind of
you know Casey's looking about this is
absolutely core to her being and I think
what you've seen here is you know Liz
trots have in in basically because of
the Tory's kind of big spending term you
know everyone has to make a choice
between yeah or which they they value
more you know sounds like you know sound
public finances you know balanced
budgets and all that all tax cuts as K
Andrews writes a coffee house literally
watching a plant look list trust and
quality quantity have firmly plumped for
tax cuts that that is what matters I
don't think she is going to back away
from those tax cards come what may I
think if she was in a position I think I
think that's not go ahead of ourselves I
mean we're getting mad yeah but you know
if she had to do something
much more likely to be spending and in
the past I mean I remember when I spoke
to her in in France when she was foreign
secretary a week before uh Boris Johnson
uh ultimately was pushed out and she did
talk about how money could be saved in
other departments so you get the sense
that that is politically difficult with
the current Coalition but that is where
she would go if she was up against the
law I wonder if that's the current she
hasn't played yet though I mean because
today wasn't to say she wasn't a budget
but perhaps you know they do intend
later on to come up with spending cards
mind you they've said so much extra the
borrowing I mean I have found that the
political choreography if they are
planning to come up with spending cuts
the political choreography was odd to
not put it all out there at the same
time no especially not if you want to
assuage the markets
um but but I guess this this will be the
big question though will they wear it I
think not just for the next few weeks or
the next few days will be very anxious
ones in the treasury just to see how
well this will will go down yeah and
just finally on that James we talked
about 18 months in terms of how long she
has probably to the next election and
but how much time did she have really in
terms of
right now everyone's looking at the
markets and people say you know this is
landing badly
how much time has she got to really show
this is working has she got months or
are people getting Panic a bit well we
have a floating currency and so
therefore she has more time I mean so
you know people trying to draw
comparisons of events of 30 years ago
are are way off base because you know
that there isn't some dramatic moment in
which people will say oh that that this
has worked always hasn't worked I I
think the danger for her is actually
about is what you saw to this podcast on
it's about political Capital you know if
you have kind of continuing you know bad
news from the markets she will have less
of a hold over her party you'll have
you'll hear more dissenting voices it'll
be more difficult for her to get her way
and I think also things like you know
the public sector unions will be more
prepared to push hard for big pay Rises
because they will think that she's in a
more politically vulnerable situation
um I I think the I I think the challenge
here is you know she I think has a
mandate for what she is doing from the
Tory membership but UPS uh I think I
think there are you know Tory MPS who
are nervous about this and I think that
you know I think in terms of you know
Julian Smith I think was the kind of has
kind of gone public without there's no
small thing for a former Chief Wick but
I think it I think the question is you
know is there a sense that this is
beginning to deliver in in terms of
getting growth going because that is
everything turns on whether it can do
that or not because you know they
haven't built the expectations up as you
know if we can do this we can avoid a
deep recession we can kind of get the
contribute that's about too much damage
they have said that you know they can
get to 2.5
I wonder what the tomorrow's papers are
going to look like I mean normally after
the such a big tax cut giveaway you'd
expect very favorable headlines the
chancellor has done this biggest tax cut
in the generation Etc and of course that
normally happens after a period of
growth where there are dividends and you
can celebrate the growth by giving a tax
cut that is typically how governments
tend to work this time is the opposite
everything is going terribly badly so
you think you have a massive tax cut as
a kind of Hail Mary pass we better hope
this will work because nothing else will
so there is a feeling of nervousness now
rather than celebration even though we
we are talking about the biggest tax
cutting budget for 50 years and
something that will make almost
everybody in this country better off as
a result of today's announcements anyway
if you look at it in the round of course
we're just looking really at the tax
burden going back to where it was about
five or six years ago so this doesn't
going back decades but it's it's funny
that's to think with so much spending
has been done today so much has been so
much tax has been cut and I don't think
that Liz truss and quasi-court I am
going to be taking bounds in front of
the much of the media tomorrow but we'll
see the jury is out thank you Fraser
thank you James and thank you for
watching